[Music]
so we're back part 2 and we are throwing
a holiday potluck that's right we're
inviting a bunch of our friends
coworkers
closest acquaintances to a potluck that
we're having a little bit later but
today we're going to be seeing some of
those desserts that are gonna show up at
the bottom of one of them is going to be
homemade and one of them is going to
come from a bakery here in Los Angeles
we're on our way downtown to the PI
point where we hopefully put some pie
into our pie policies bless you
sneeze hole back there Google how is
traffic to the pie hole downtown there's
light traffic from your location to the
pie hole so it'll take about 28 minutes
okay
hi-ho silver away hi I'm Sean Brennan
I'm one of the founders of the pie hole
today we're here at our original
location and we're gonna try some of her
awesome holiday pie tell us about the
pie hole the file was founded in 2011
we're coming out of a terrible economy
and people were looking for something
that made them feel good which is
comfort food we always think about what
could be served at the dinner table you
can't disappoint grandma and it also has
to impress your friends who have really
high expectations joining us in the
kitchen today is gonna be Bianca and
she's gonna take us through the making
of all of our awesome on holiday
selections I am bianca molina
i'm the director of training for the
panel which pies are making the ACMA
today we're starting off with the mom's
apple crumble the mom's apple crumble
has a butter crust we salute it make it
super pretty then we go ahead and we
dump our apple mix inside it's too
worth of apples we top it off with our
house-made crumble bake it off for about
30 to 45 minutes and it's ready to serve
and so this is it has a crumble topping
and not like a pastry topping we've done
the pastry crust top we've done a poodle
top but this one is what guests love so
we do it and then our newest pie it's
the salted chocolate it's on a pretzel
crust then you had a dark chocolate
ganache super thick and decadent then we
top it off with olive oil sprinkle it
with a little bit of sea salt flakes
then it's topped off with pomegranate
it adds lots of flavor makes it a little
bit refreshing really juicy might be my
new favorite line then the third pie
will be me vaulted caramel pecan we add
pecans
then our secret little caramel filling
the pecans rise to the top we finish it
off with a little bit of sea salt we
bake it off and then you have our salted
caramel sauce the Earl Grey he was put
on the menu
when Downton Abbey came back guests
loved it we haven't taken it off since
it's got a layer of dark chocolate
ganache salted pistachios then you have
our Earl Grey tea infused white
chocolate mousse we've brewed the Earl
Grey team it seats overnight and then we
cook off the mousse then it's topped
with house-made wet screamed and roasted
salted pistachios it's funny because I
don't think that's really much tea
flavoured pie it's like a pie that is
this whole new delicious flavor that
happens to be your old right
I should not have said it better please
you make pies but you're also you do the
coffee I do the coffee so what was your
first job here I was a barista
I've loved coffee my entire life my
great-great-grandfather was the largest
coffee importer in Nicaragua and it's
something that you know I just grew up
really admiring and now I oversee our
coffee program as well it's always
topped - your coffee we roast it locally
and when we serve it to our guests we do
it with lots of love okay we got a
little taste before we head over to the
potluck and of course we're not gonna
leave without drinking some coffee
[Music]
Apple first
oh my goodness you're normal
oh yeah you know sometimes you have a
problem with pie where the top Crescent
breaks off and you run out of it very
quickly as it all falls off with the
crumble each little bit of apple has a
little bit of the topping yeah okay we
got a pearl-grey pie whoa
different as a hint of Earl Grey tea but
it's not really Justin your old grape
flavor so much reminds me of a
cheesecake this is truly one of the most
unique desserts I've ever heard yeah
they're gonna be expecting like a heavy
pie you know but then they're gonna get
a light refreshing pie and then mine
well that you can have pie and feel
skyhigh at same time damn almost like
spit some sick bars yeah I did yeah
those pies are gonna be delicious yeah
they were delicious now we're on our way
to Rea sorry eh if you didn't know is
quite an avid dessert eater and maker
and she's going to be making something
for our potluck called croquembouche
I've never had a croquembouche before I
have never had a croquembouche either I
haven't a croque in my throat's though
you go but not in your bouche Irie a
thank you for doing the call of your
thoughts oh yeah thank you for having me
this is weird
cuz you've done interviews with us so
who are you I'm Leanne the pasty produce
what are you making for our potluck I'm
making croquembouche croquembouche it's
a cream puff power but I'm going to make
it a lotion barrette so some of the
cream puffs hearts cream some of the
cream puff hats wasabi
that the VA special mm-hmm we didn't ask
you to do that but I'm glad you just
wanted to do it anyway it's pretty so
you have to have a game right yeah so
it's like a fun game so first do you
make Papa shew-whee cheats choux pastry
you own buying water and butter and
bring it to a boil then add a pinch of
salt for flavor
and you shift the flour and combine at
once and you just mix very fast and once
the dough form like a bowl you're going
to take off from the heat and add egg
one by one I love making dessert my mom
is a chef so they used to have a small
cafe but whenever she made pastry at
home like I just get really excited
because it doesn't happen often so I
think that's the reason I really start
liking making dessert and what kind of
cream are you filling them with I'm
going to combine custard cream and
whipped cream and a combine together and
what is better about custard than just
like filling it with whipped cream
I just grown up eating with custard and
heavy cream filling in Japan I think
it's the most common way but I think if
we two just cost that it's too heavy if
it's just whipped cream it's a little
bit boring so I like two together and I
like the flavor better when you pipe it
in the bottom of your make cross cut so
it's easy to pipe make sure you don't
fail too much because we need to become
heavy it's more difficult to make the
power when you're making caramel
don't touch it leave it until 8 3 2 335
so the caramel is like the glue for this
tower mm-hmm yes which you're going to
help me today help you make the tower
yeah is that like the heart the
important part is the important part the
help okay yeah
so it's just dick and dip and stick so
you used to work in restaurants but you
weren't a dessert chef necessarily I
majored cutting alright and then when I
start walking out the restaurant
I asked pastry chef can I also walk for
pastry station so I walked up the savory
station for three days a week and two
days a week
I did ask pastry station when you make
bazaar you don't make it for yourself
you're making for somebody else I like
the element of that sharing food
especially like something special it's
people Shh why did you select
croquembouche for our Holi table I
wanted to make something sort of a
retreat
I made a croquembouche only once but
I've made cream past thousand times
because it's my favorite dessert to make
I like the transformation I like
watching it pops up all right we got the
croquembouche it looks delicious can we
do a little bit of a test tasting yeah
leftover leftover is not eating that
wasabi I want it I'm gonna eat a regular
one Stephens brave enough to have the
wasabi how strong is the wasabi one to
ten scale yes eight is it like eating a
glob of wasabi yeah all right
we're Savin tears
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it
tomorrow is the big day potluck dang man
wouldn't it be a shame if you also got
this on the night of the fire really
Hall are you okay mm-hmm om that is so
strong it's everywhere this is really
cruel that is broken Boosh rushing to
the way high five tomorrow's a big day
potluck day
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]